hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live meine ehrliche Frage habt ihr da
draußen heute schon tiktok benutzt um
die App die mittlerweile weltweit sogar
1,7 Milliarden Menschen nutzen um die
ging es heute in den USA da droht
Präsident Joe Biden nämlich mit einem
Verbot der App und darauf reagieren
aktuell viele junge Leute so
per WhatsApp
ja die Wut und das Unverständnis gerade
in der jungen Bevölkerung darüber ist
groß aus US-Sicht ist aber die Gefahr
von Spionage und Einflussnahme über
diese tiktok App durch die chinesische
Regierung groß beiden hat jetzt den
Besitzern der App quasi so eine Art
Ultimatum gestellt entweder sie
verkaufen die App in den USA oder die
App wird tatsächlich landesweit verboten
und deswegen musste sich heute der
tiktoks CEO vom US-Kongress erklären und
da hat er unter anderem folgendes gesagt
wir haben so etwas wie eine Firewall
aufgebaut die unsere Benutzerdaten vor
unbefugten Zugriff aus dem Ausland
schützt die Quintessenz ist folgende
amerikanische Daten sind auf
amerikanischen Boden gespeichert von
einem amerikanischen Unternehmen das von
amerikanischen Personal beaufsichtigt
wird wir nennen diese Initiative Projekt
Texas
ja über dieses Projekt Texas sprechen
wir gleich noch ein tiktok Verbot könnte
fast die Hälfte aller US-Amerikaner und
Amerikanerinnen betreffen denn nach
Angaben von tiktok wird die App dort von
mehr als 150 Millionen US-Amerikanern
und Amerikanerinnen genutzt was diese
tiktok Verteidigung im Kongress heute
bedeutet hat wie die lief und wie sehr
die chinesische Regierung wirklich mit
dieser App die ja total viele Menschen
nutzen verwandelt ist darüber sprechen
wir heute zum einen mit meinem Kollegen
in Washington Elmer Tierwesen dann mit
Antonia maidi vom mercator-institut for
China studies und mit it-rechtler
Professor Dennis Kenji Kipka von der
Hochschule Bremen aber wie immer
sprechen nicht nur ich mit denen sondern
ich will dass ihr euch auch einmischt
wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema habt oder
einfach mal eure Meinung loswerden wollt
dann schreibt mir gerne hier im Youtube
Chat oder per Mail an ZDF
an die Mail-Adresse die da eingeblendet
ist bei mir steht sie nämlich gerade
nicht jetzt schalte ich aber erstmal zu
meinem Kollegen Emma Tiere sind in
Washington der ist quasi live vor Ort
hallo Emma
hallo Viktoria hallo ja da wo du gerade
stehst da hat sich heute der tik Tokyo
vor dem US-Kongress erklärt gegen was
für Vorwürfe musste der sich da genau
verteidigen und wie hat er sich dabei
geschlagen
ja es war ja eine Anhörung nicht weit
von hier ein paar Meter in einem der
Häuser der Abgeordneten wo diese
Anhörung stattfand und diese
Abgeordneten des Repräsentantenhauses
haben vor allen Dingen zwei sorgen die
eine ist sie glauben dass die Daten die
gesammelt werden bei tiktok und die
werden gesammelt was die auch
weitergereicht werden können an die
chinesische Regierung und an die
chinesischen Geheimdienste also es wäre
so eine Art Werkzeug um Amerikaner
auszusehen das ist das eine und das
andere das tiktok eben Inhalte
verbreitet mit denen es die öffentliche
Meinung die Menschen hier in den USA
manipulieren könnte in dem es
möglicherweise auch zulässt das Lügen
verbreitet werden und ähnliches das war
die Hauptsorge der Abgeordneten das
haben wir vorhin hier bei der Anhörung
gehört der tiktok Chef selber ist hier
so ein bisschen als Anwalt der 150
Millionen User aufgetreten er will im
Grunde am klar machen dass tiktok
eigentlich nur ein Ziel hat neben dem
Geld verdienen natürlich nämlich dass
die Menschen ihre freie Meinungsäußerung
nutzen können dass sie kreativ sind mit
all dem was auf tiktok gemacht wird hat
darauf hingewiesen dass tiktok oft auch
dazu beiträgt dass Menschen Geschäfte
machen können das auch kleine Betriebe
beispielsweise Vorteile davon haben wenn
sie tiktok benutzen um Werbung zu machen
und ähnliches jetzt kommt das aber er
musste natürlich erklären wie er
verhindern will dass alle diese Daten
tatsächlich am Ende in die Hände der
chinesischen Geheimdienste kommen und
das macht er mit diesem Projekt Texas
also das ist das der Plan dass man auf
Servern hier in den USA auf
amerikanischen Boden die nicht tiktok
gehören sondern der Firma Oracle alle
Daten von amerikanischen Nutzern
speichert nichts geht also irgendwo
anders hin und dass diese dieser Vorgang
dieses speichern und die Nutzung dieser
Daten überwacht wird von Dritten von
unabhängigen die nichts mit der Firma
tiktok zu tun haben das hört sich alles
gut an aber viele Abgeordnete haben
daraufhin gesagt wir glauben ihnen das
nicht sie treten hier im Grunde mal
seine auf der einen ein positives
Beispiel setzen will gute Absichten hat
aber in Wahrheit eben nicht verhindern
kann dass diese Daten abfließen und die
Abgeordneten Stützen dass eben darauf
dass tatsächlich in China seit 2017 ein
Gesetz gilt das für alle Firmen alle
Privatfirmen in China auch Gültigkeit
hat nämlich dass Sie alle Daten alle
Informationen die Sie gewinnen in ihren
Geschäften auch auf Anfrage weitergeben
müssen an die chinesischen Geheimdienste
und die chinesische Regierung
ja danke erstmal für diese Einschätzung
hier in der Community herrscht gerade so
ein bisschen Unklarheit hier fragt
jemand auf Facebook hat Donald Trump so
ein Verbot nicht schon vor Jahren
gefordert was ist denn eigentlich damit
passiert
ja das hat er tatsächlich gefordert und
dann hat man aber dafür gesorgt also
china hat dann Einspruch eingelegt was
übrigens heute hier als Beleg dafür
genommen wird dass die chinesische
Regierung tatsächlich letztlich die
ultimative Hoheit hat auch über diese
App tiktok die ja als Firma eigentlich
einem chinesischen Unternehmen
unterstellt ist der Firma beidance
tiktok selber sitzt nur in den USA und
den Singapur und nicht in China selber
deswegen versucht der Chef hier klar zu
machen hey wir haben mit der
chinesischen Regierung nichts zu tun
aber die führende Persönlichkeiten des
Mutterkonzerns haben wichtige Rollen
auch in der Kommunistischen Partei
Chinas deswegen befürchtet man den
Zugriff Donald Trump hat versucht tiktok
zu verbieten das hat sich nicht
durchsetzen lassen hier in Amerika er
hat dann auch aufgefordert dass man
tiktok verkaufen muss und da hat die
chinesische Regierung auch eine Bremse
eingezogen sie hat nämlich dann
handelsschränkungen erlassen nach denen
die Algorithmen über die tiktok verfügt
eben nicht an Dritte weitergegeben
werden können also nicht an
amerikanische Firmen wenn man tiktok
hierher verkaufen wollte und dadurch
wurde das damals gestoppt das versuchen
die Politiker hier jetzt auszuhebeln
indem sie ein neues Gesetz schaffen das
dem amerikanischen Präsidenten
tatsächlich die Möglichkeit gibt
entweder dafür zu sorgen dass tiktok
verkauft wird oder am Ende tiktok zu
verbieten in den USA
du hast gerade schon angesprochen dass
sich der tiktok ceo-show zieht Schuh so
ein bisschen auch als der Anwalt der sag
mal Community heute gegeben hat und es
ist ja auch so dass ich vom Kongress zum
einen Menschen versammelt haben die
absolut gegen so ein Verbot sind das
sind Creator also Menschen die auf
dieser Plattform Inhalte machen und zum
Teil auch damit Geld verdienen andere
Demonstranten sind hingegen für einen
Verbot was sind das für zwei Gruppen und
was sind deren Argumente
ja die einen sind natürlich die die
sagen sie profitieren jetzt nicht alle
finanziell von tiktok aber eben indem
sie ihrer Kreativität freien Lauf halten
erlassen können indem sie sich vernetzen
können mit Menschen rund um den Erdball
und dass man sich für eine Sache
gemeinsam begeistern kann also die
positive Seite von tiktok betonen sie
und das sind junge Leute aus ganz
Amerika aber auch zum Beispiel die
großen
Bürgerrechtsbewegungen in den USA die
sagen wenn es hier ein Verbot gäbe wäre
das eine Einschränkung der
Meinungsfreiheit sie haben nichts
dagegen dass man Regeln macht die gibt
es hier in Amerika noch nicht so sehr
wie in Europa beispielsweise was
Datenschutz angeht aber sie wollen eben
nicht dass tiktok verboten wird und auf
der anderen Seite gibt es die die sagen
doch es muss ein Verbot her die werden
glaube ich in erster Linie getrieben von
der Sorge dass Inhalte verbreitet werden
die ich sag mal schädlich sein könnten
das beispielsweise Inhalte verbreitet
werden wo es um die Selbsttötung
Selbstmorde geht oder wo es um
Gewalt und Hass und ähnliches geht und
tatsächlich wurden die ja vorhin in der
Anhörung auch einige Beispiele gezeigt
Inhalte auf tiktok die man vermutlich
auch ähnlich auf anderen Plattformen
Social Media Plattformen finden kann die
tatsächlich zweifeln lassen ob wirklich
sorgfältig genug überprüft wird ob der
Inhalte verbreit wäre verbreitet werden
die zur Gewalt aufrufen es wurde vorhin
ein Video hier gezeigt dass im Grunde
genommen indirekt zur Gewalt aufgerufen
hat gegen die
Vorsitzende dieses Ausschusses der hier
heute tagte und eine Abgeordnete hat
dann den tiktok Chef massiv unter Druck
gesetzt aber dann ihm auch gar nicht
Gelegenheit gegeben zu antworten darauf
da wurde er dann im Wort abgeschnitten
und das zeigt so ein bisschen die
Stimmung hier weil quer durch die Bank
war das das was wir hier bei der
Anhörung erlebt haben dass der tiktok
Chef Mühe hatte seine Argumente
vorzubringen weil offenbar die
überwältigende Mehrheit der Abgeordnete
ihre Meinung schon gebildet haben ja
auch Teil gefällt haben und über tiktok
und ein Verbot fordern
ja wir sehen eine ziemlich aufgehitzte
Stimmung an diesem Tag dieser Anhörung
wie geht es denn jetzt weiter Joe Biden
hat ja gesagt entweder die App wird in
den USA verkauft oder die App wird
verboten wann kann man da denn mit den
nächsten Schritten rechnen nach diesem
Tag
also ich glaube die Frage des Verkaufs
hat sich eigentlich erledigt der
chinesische Wirtschaftsminister hat sich
öffentlich geäußert und klar gemacht
dass das nicht in Frage kommt weil eben
dann ja Technologie Algorithmen die
China als Eigentum einer chinesischen
Firma ansieht dann an Dritte an die
Amerikaner weitergegeben werden könnte
also man wird alles daran setzen das zu
verhindern dass tiktok hier in den USA
verkauft werden muss Joe Biden hat am
Ende im Grunde genommen kann er die
Auflage machen aber wenn die dann nicht
erfüllt wird dann bleibt eigentlich nur
der Weg zum verboten und tatsächlich
wird das in den nächsten Wochen weiter
vorangetrieben hier liegen
Gesetzentwürfe in den beiden Häusern das
Kongresses man wird sich am Ende auf
einen Entwurf verständigen und dann
steht der Präsiden Frankfurter
entscheidenden Frage macht der strikte
Auflagen versucht trotzdem das tik tok
verkauft wird wie gesagt china will
nicht mitmachen oder verhängt er dann
ein Verbot und dann ist aber auch
wiederum die große Frage wie will man
das denn durchsetzen man müsste ja dafür
sorgen dass die App nirgendwo mehr
runtergeladen werden könnte dass man sie
nirgendwo auf seinem Endgerät mehr
nutzen könnte es gibt technische
Möglichkeiten dafür aber der Präsident
muss damit rechnen dass er dann verklagt
wird eben von Bürgerrechtsgruppen die
sagen das ist eine Einschränkung der
Meinungsfreiheit also ich glaube dass
sich der ganze Prozess wahrscheinlich
noch Monate wenn ich sogar Jahre
hinziehen wird
wir bleiben auf jeden Fall gespannt dran
und du denke ich auch danke erstmal für
diese ersten Einschätzung
bitte
ja wir haben es gerade schon gehört wenn
es um die App tiktok geht das ist das
Logo was ihr hier hinter mir seht dann
geht es irgendwie immer auch um diese
Firma um dieses Unternehmen bei Dennis
das ist das chinesische Unternehmen zu
dem tiktok quasi dazu gehört Jonas Cup
und Lena jentscha haben sich dieses
Unternehmen für uns mal genauer
angeschaut
Gründer und Betreiber von tiktok ist der
chinesische Tech Gigant bei Dance das
Unternehmen gilt als das wertvollste
Start-up der Welt 10 Jahre nach seiner
Gründung wurde es 2022 mit rund 300
Milliarden Dollar bewährt
belastbare Zahlen zu
Unternehmensentwicklung und Größe sind
rar gesät 2021 arbeiteten wohl etwa
130.000 Menschen für beides nach
tiktok-angaben ist bei Dance zu 60% im
Besitz westlicher Investoren darunter
auch die global agierende New Yorker
Investment Bank Goldman Sachs die
restlichen 40% verteilen sich angeblich
je zur Hälfte auf die Mitarbeiter und
die Gründer des Unternehmens
kritiker werfen im Unternehmen vor zu
stark vom chinesischen Staat beeinflusst
zu sein eine staatliche
Investmentgesellschaft hat einen Anteil
von einem Prozent ein Vertreter der
Kommunistischen Partei sitzt im Vorstand
bei Dance kontrolliert nicht nur die
Geschäfte der tiktok App sondern auch
die der chinesischen Version Julien
[Musik]
ja das wissen vielleicht einige gar
nicht chinesische Menschen haben gar
keinen Zugriff auf die nutzen eine
andere Version die heißt dort duien auf
dieses Unternehmen wollen wir jetzt noch
mal genauer gucken und auch darauf
welche politischen Interessen China in
diesem Streit aktuell vertreten darüber
sprechen jetzt mit Antonia mai die mir
zugeschaltet ist hallo Frau Idee sie ist
Expertin von der Karte Institut für
China
wir haben jetzt eben schon so ein
bisschen die amerikanische Seite dieses
Konflikts gehört können Sie uns sagen
wie guckt in China jetzt aktuell auf
diesen Tag auf diese Anhörung im
Kongress
ja guckt auf diese Anhörung sehr
kritisch sie sagen solch eine Anhörung
sollte es nicht geben tiktok macht genau
das gleiche wie amerikanische Filmen und
amerikanische filmen da wird darüber
diskutiert dass sie vielleicht ein
bisschen besser reguliert werden sollen
aber natürlich nicht darüber dass die
verboten werden sollen und in Chinesisch
aus chinesischer Sicht wird das dann
auch oft auf die größere
geopolitische Lage zurückgeführt wurde
dann eben gesagt wird okay die wollen so
China eins auswischen und deswegen
nehmen Sie jetzt tiktok in der Hoffnung
China damit richtig eins auszuwischen
das ist so die chinesische Sicht die
natürlich also wenn man sich so stark
mit den anschaut natürlich einige
Argumente davon machen durchaus Sinn
amerikanischen Film machen sehr ähnliche
Dinge eine andere Argumente sind
natürlich dann auch ein bisschen weit
hergeholt weil ich China eben keinen
demokratisches Land ist was die USA zum
Beispiel durch ist
ja da haben wir auch ein paar Fragen aus
der Community zu die aber damit auch
schon so ein bisschen geklärt sind
inwiefern ist denn jetzt eine wirklich
gefährlicher als der breit gestreute
Besitz amerikanischer Film durch China
weil WhatsApp Instagram Facebook das
haben wir auch alle von seinem Handys
ja das ist natürlich eine ganz gute
Frage und das ist tatsächlich eigentlich
die die wichtigste Frage die aber super
schwierig zu beantworten ist dadurch
dass es in China so intransparent ist
wissen wir einfach nicht inwiefern die
chinesische Partei da irgendwie genau
Kontrolle über tiktok haben kann oder
hat wir wissen dass tiktok und vor allem
bei Dance als chinesische Firma wobei
bei Dance offiziell in Cayman Islands
ist aber es ist trotzdem eine
chinesische Firma würde ich sagen ähm
eben chinesischen Gesetzen unterliegt
und es gibt dadurch ausgesetzte die im
sagen alle Daten wenn der chinesische
Staat Fragen Daten anfragt dann müssen
diese Daten
an China gegeben werden es gibt auch und
das ist vielleicht der andere der andere
Teil wir wissen dass China beim
chinesischen Äquivalent also bei
dauerien sehr großen Einfluss hat wir
wissen dass es eben der chinesische
Stadt hat irgendwie ein Prozent von
einer Tochtergesellschaft von Bike dance
vielleicht irgendwie bei Dance Peking
und hat da daraufhin auch einen Fluss
auf den Algorithmus von daugien den und
eben auch die Entscheidungen zu Inhalten
von dauian wir wissen nicht genau wie
der Algorithmus von daugien und der
Algorithmus von tiktok Zusammenhängen
das heißt es gibt durchaus die
Möglichkeit dass der oder wir wissen
dass der Algorithmus sehr ähnlich ist es
wäre nicht sonderlich schwierig zum
Beispiel in einem Teil des Algorithmus
zu sagen okay wir möchten jetzt
chinesische Staatsmedien besonders
bevorzugen teil und im tiktok Teil das
nicht sagen aber es wäre eben auch
möglich dass sie das einfach nicht
machen und das ist das schwierige wo das
eben auch so schwierig ist für uns jetzt
einzuschätzen weil wir einfach nicht
wissen wie diese Situation ist wie es
wirklich aussieht inwiefern bei Dance
jetzt wirklich sehr enge Kontakte zu
chinesischen Partei hat inwiefern die
Partei da jetzt wirklich schon angefragt
hat und Daten auch bekommen hat das
wissen wir einfach nicht und im
chinesischen System gibt es auch keinen
guten Weg das rauszufinden
ja zu diesem Besitzverhältnissen bei
weit denn da habe ich noch mal einen Ton
von heute den ich mir gerne noch mal mit
ihnen angucken würde
bei Dance ist nicht im Besitz oder unter
Kontrolle der chinesischen Regierung es
ist ein privates Unternehmen 60% des
Unternehmens gehören globalen
institutionellen Anlegern 20% im Grunde
und 20% in Mitarbeitern weltweit bei
Dance hat fünf Vorstandsmitglieder drei
von ihnen sind Amerikaner tiktok selbst
ist nicht in China erhältlich wir haben
unseren Hauptsitz in Los Angeles und
Singapur in den USA haben wir 7000
Mitarbeiter
verstehe ich das richtig wir haben also
einmal die weit Dance Firma über die
hier gesprochen wird und was sie gerade
erzählt haben ist das bei Dance ne
Tochterfirma hat bei Dance basing und da
hat der chinesische Staat also einen
gewissen Einfluss oder
bei dieser Tochterfirma bei beiden
spaging hat der chinesische Staat einen
großen Einfluss er hilft dabei oder er
muss konsultiert werden also der
Direktor dieser der von chinesischen
Staat ernannt wurde muss konzentriert
werden wenn es um
strategieentscheidungen geht von der
Tochterfirma von bite Dance die aber
einen riesigen Anteil von so der
elternfirma bei Dance hat natürlich also
irgendwie dojen und tiktok und in dem
Fall auch tot ja diese drei Dinge sind
zusammen ein riesiger Anteil der
beidance Firma aber die genauen
Besitzverhältnis die genauen wir kennen
die Besitzverhältnisse aber die genauen
Verhältnisse in Bezug auf inwiefern
werden jetzt Entscheidungen nach oben
von oben beeinflusst oder eben auch
inwiefern beeinflussen sie nach oben das
wissen wir eben nicht
jetzt gab es ja im Dezember den Vorfall
das tatsächlich mehrere US-Journalist in
ausgespielt wurden daraufhin hat tiktok
die entsprechenden Mitarbeiter in aus
der Firma entlassen sowas wirft ja dann
aber schon Fragen auf oder
auf der einen Seite wirft sowas
natürlich Fragen auf auf der anderen
Seite ich meine wenn wir uns den
Cambridge analytica Skandal anschauen
das ist was das irgendwie diese großen
Tech Firmen inhärent haben in diesem
Fall ging es nicht darum dass tiktok
diese Daten an die chinesische Regierung
gegeben hat sondern tiktok wollte oder
manche Mitarbeiter in von tiktok wollten
herausfinden wie kamen diese
JournalistInnen an ihre Informationen
über tiktok das heißt es war natürlich
illegal und natürlich auch nicht in
Ordnung aber es war jetzt nicht nichts
was zum Beispiel für was z.B bei
Facebook nicht passieren könnte oder bei
Meta inzwischen
wir haben hier mal eine Frage aus der
Community auch noch zu diesem Vorwurf 1
es gibt ja aktuell zwei Vorwürfe von US
Seite und Vorwurf 1 ist eben die
Datensicherheit und Datensammlung durch
tiktok und jetzt fragt Natalia auf
Youtube was hat China davon wenn es weiß
dass Selina auf tiktok dumme Tänze zeigt
mal im Ernst gefragt ich glaube das ist
eine Umstand da fragen sich gerade ganz
viele junge Menschen
ja ich meine natürlich kann man das gut
Fragen und bei den meisten Selinas gilt
das bestimmt da hat China jetzt nicht so
viel davon das Problem ist was ist mit
den Selinas die in zehn Jahren beim
deutschen Geheimdienst beim
amerikanischen Geheimdienst beim
deutschen Wirtschaftsministerium
anfangen und wenn man eben diese Daten
hat das gilt übrigens nicht nur für den
chinesischen Geheimdienst das gilt für
alle Geheimdienste dann kann man
möglicherweise einen langzeitprofil von
Menschen aufmachen wir wissen dass
tiktok Entschuldigung wir wissen dass
China
2015/2016 sehr viele Daten aus den USA
gestohlen hat durch einen Hack und zwar
waren das Daten die
der die über regierungs- und da könnte
man jetzt zum Beispiel gucken okay
welche dieser regierungsmitarbeitende
sind auf tiktok wie kann man vielleicht
über die etwas rausfinden wo die sich
jetzt aufhalten was die gerade machen
viele von denen da ist es natürlich
nicht so transparent wenn du jetzt zum
Beispiel in den Geheimdienst gewechselt
haben dann steht da meistens nicht die
sind jetzt im Geheimdienst dann könnte
man vielleicht rausfinden oh die fahren
immer nach langem die sind
wahrscheinlich da schon da da gibt es
schon Möglichkeiten das sind aber
meistens sehr gezielte Dinge das heißt
ich ähm wenn der das ist eher so man
weiß wenn man wenn man treffen möchte
und diese Person kann man dann eben
gezielt suchen
okay so viel also mal zu Vorwurf 1 der
heute diskutiert wurde Vorwurf 2 an die
tiktok App ist ja das Nutzer in dieser
App durch Propaganda über den
Algorithmus beeinflusst werden jetzt
haben wir eben gehört es gibt einmal
dojum für Chinesin es gibt tiktok für
alle anderen wie realistisch ist es denn
jetzt das die Betreiber der duium-app
also die wo die chinesische Regierung
einen Einfluss hat auch ein Einfluss
darauf nehmen was wir bei tiktok sehen
also das ist tatsächlich auch wieder
etwas das nicht so einfach zu
beantworten ist wir wissen dass jojen
der oder wir wissen dass der Algorithmus
von tiktok und da gehen zum Großteil
zusammen
entwickelt wird einfach und dann ist
natürlich die Frage okay was bedeutet
das jetzt wie ist dieser Algorithmus
aufgebaut und das große Problem ist dass
wir nicht wissen wie diese Algorithmus
aufgebaut ist und das tiktok
argumentiert das ist aber unser
Geheimnis das möchten wir nicht sagen
das heißt wir können das nicht
rausfinden inwiefern das jetzt wirklich
so ist das irgendwie z.B chinesische
Propaganda mehr gezeigt wird es gibt ein
paar Beispiele die dann eben auch
schnell geändert wurden z.B war es lange
Zeit so dass chinesische Staatsmedien
nicht als Staatsmedien gekennzeichnet
waren und ein tiktok und dass diese
Staatsmedien eben auch durchaus
Reichweite bekommen haben das gilt aber
auch für andere Medien das war jetzt
nicht so dass das nur chinesische
Staatsmedien waren aber das große
Problem ist eben und das ist ein Problem
dass wir bei allen Apps haben dass wir
den Algorithmus einfach nicht kennen
nicht wissen und deswegen nicht
rausfinden können ob da irgendwie im
Manipulationen dabei ist oder ob da
keine Manipulation dabei ist
ja vielleicht können wir abschließend
noch mal auf das größere Bild gucken
jetzt fragen sich bestimmt gerade ganz
viele warum streiten sich zwei Staaten
so um eine Video-App steckt da
vielleicht eigentlich mehr hinter als
der Streit um Tanz und Kochvideos also
was sagt uns das über die geopolitische
Lage in der sich die USA und China
gerade befinden
ich denke die USA und China haben beide
für sich entschieden dass die digitale
Wirtschaft das digitale die Technologie
sozusagen der neue
supermachtkampfplatz sein wird also die
USA möchte gerne weiterhin Supermacht
bleiben china möchte gerne zumindest
auch aufsteigen zur Supermacht wenn ich
da die USA überholen und beide haben für
sich entschieden dass sie der Ansicht
sind das Technologie der Weg also für
China ist das der Weg in eben eine
Supermacht zu werden für die USA ist das
der Weg eine super Macht zu bleiben und
vor diesem Hintergrund sind dann auch
sehr viele dieser was wir momentan mit
Vorarbeit zum Beispiel sehen
durchaus mehr vielleicht verständlicher
das ist eben nicht unbedingt um tiktok
oder Huawei an sich geht sondern eher
darum wer wird in Zukunft die
Vorherrschaft auf der Welt haben und
gerade wenn man gerade bei tiktok wo man
eben so viele Leute also so viele
Menschen sind darauf da kann man dann
eben durchaus sagen okay wer tiktok
besitzt der kann
möglicherweise Menschen manipulieren der
hat möglicherweise sehr viele Daten aber
vor allem hat der auch so ein sehr gutes
Zeichen nach außen gesetzt wir sind eine
große wichtige macht und wir und unsere
digital Produkte sind international
irgendwie attraktiv und sind
international auch attraktiver als
vielleicht andere digitalprodukte und
das ist aus meiner Sicht auch einer der
Gründe warum China und Chinas Regierung
da so stark dagegen sind eben tiktok zu
verkaufen das geht da geht es ganz viel
und Prestige darum als Supermacht als
groß macht als digitale Welt macht
wahrgenommen zu werden und in den USA
geht es immer mehr darum dass eben der
Status der USA als erste Welt nach der
Welt und gleichzeitig eben auch der
Status des liberalen Systems wie es so
schön genannt wird international
behalten wird
ja wir sehen da liegt auf jeden Fall ein
größerer Konflikt hinter danke Frau auch
mal die Idee dass sie meine und die
Fragen der Community beantwortet haben
ich werfe tschüss
ich werfe gerade mal so ein Blick in die
Kommentare und interessanterweise sind
unter euch ziemlich viele gegen ein
tiktok Verbot hier schreibt zum Beispiel
der Zentralrat der Schwaben auf Youtube
ich nutze keinen tiktok zum Glück auf
von mir kann es komplett verboten werden
ja da ist gleich mal die Perspektive bei
uns hier in Deutschland was hat dieser
Streit in den USA jetzt eigentlich mit
uns zu tun hier in Deutschland hier in
der EU wir nutzen tiktok ja auch ist und
verbot bei uns oder zumindest die
Diskussion um einen Verbot wie sie
gerade in den USA hat überhaupt
realistisch dazu spreche ich jetzt mit
it-rechner Professor Dennis kenjiker
hallo Herr
guten Abend
ja dieser ganze verbotsstreit den wir da
gerade mitbekommen was hat der denn mit
uns zu tun bzw wie realistisch ist diese
Diskussion eigentlich für uns hier in
der EU
also das hat tatsächlich ganz viel mit
uns zu tun weil tiktok wird natürlich
auch von sehr sehr viel Nutzern in der
Europäischen Union verwendet und
dementsprechend ist die Diskussion
nahezu eins zu eins auf das was wir hier
in der EU haben übertragbar natürlich
muss man sagen die Verbotsdebatte ist
sehr weit gefasst und Verboten bedeutet
natürlich nicht einfach dass eine
Regierung hingehen kann in einem
Rechtsstaat und ein Produkt was zunächst
natürlich einmal auf dem europäischen
Markt und auch der auf dem deutschen
Markt legitimerweise angeboten wird ohne
weiteres verbieten kann das heißt wir
brauchen ein behördliches Handeln im
Bereich und ähm Rechtsstaat muss eben
ein behördliches Handeln gesetzlichen
Vorschriften entsprechend gesetzlichen
Vorschriften auch genügen und wir haben
zurzeit kein Gesetz in Deutschland wo
man einfach hingehen kann und eben eine
App ähm komplett verbietet also man kann
eine App regulieren beispielsweise unter
Datenschutz Gesichtspunkten
wettbewerbsrechtlichen Gesichtspunkt
vielleicht auch kartellrechtlichen
Gesichtspunkten aber wir haben eben
zurzeit keine Handhabe dass wir hingehen
und sagen von einem Tag auf den anderen
schalten wir tiktok ab und das ist
zurzeit auch nicht das was tatsächlich
die Bundesregierung als Zielsetzung
verfolgt
jetzt haben wir heute schon gehört dass
tiktok gerade so eine Art
besänftungskurs fährt es wird immer
wieder von diesem Texas project
gesprochen wo es darum geht dass die
Daten von Menschen in den USA die tiktok
nutzen dass diese Daten auch in den USA
gespeichert werden jetzt fragt hier
gerade jemand bei YouTube wo werden denn
eigentlich die Daten von deutschen
tiktok Usern gespeichert
also tatsächlich ist es momentan noch so
dass die hauptrechenzentren von tiktok
eben in Singapur in den USA belegen sind
aber tiktok plant auch Rechenzentren in
der Europäischen Union anzusiedeln das
hätte natürlich den ganz großen Vorteil
wenn wir europäischen Nutzer haben muss
sich tiktok natürlich auch anders
europäische Datenschutzrecht halten und
wenn die Server vor Ort belegen sind
also zum Beispiel in Deutschland oder
anderen Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen
Union dann ist das schon mal ein
erhöhter Schutzfaktor was sie
Datensicherheit angeht wir reden aber
bei tik tok in erste die nicht über
Cyber Security Probleme was sie oftmals
irgendwie kommuniziert wird sondern
erster Linie über Datenschutzprobleme
das heißt können die Daten eben unbefugt
abfließen und diese Debatte ist nicht
neu die wird auch schon für andere
Social Media Apps gehört also wir haben
ja bereits auch in den Beitrag über
Facebook gesprochen es wurde über
Instagram gesprochen alle sammeln
letztlich Daten und wenn man das aus
einem juristischen Standpunkt sich
einmal anschaut dann sind zumindest zur
Zeit noch die USA rechtlich gesehen aus
datenschutzperspektive genauso unsicher
wie China das mal kurios anmuten aber
die Europäische Union fast eben
sogenannte politische
angemessenheitsbeschlüsse für die
Datennutzung und zurzeit liegt eben
weder für die Vereinigten Staaten noch
für China in solche angemessen als
Beschluss vor und der letzte
angemessenheitsbeschluss für die
Vereinigten Staaten wurde vor wenigen
Jahren gekippt eben mit der Begründung
dass sie auch mutet fast jetzt schon
kurios an die NSA umfassende Daten
zugriffsbefugnisse eben auf Nutzerdaten
europäischer User hat
ja das scheint auch unsere Zuschauer zu
beschäftigen hier schreibt jemand auf
Youtube bitte hier in Europa Facebook
und Co auch verbieten die Amis wissen ja
nur wie es gemacht wird weil sie es
selbst machen warum führen wir diese
Debatte mit zweierlei Maß wenn es einmal
um amerikanische Unternehmen geht oder
um chinesische
also tatsächlich sind die Würfel ja auch
das hat man im Rahmen der
kongressanhörung bereits gesehen
eigentlich schon gefallen also die
datenschutzrisiken sind natürlich da und
beide Staaten sind keine sicheren
Drittstaaten man muss aber ein
Unterschied hier dennoch machen also die
USA sind natürlich noch eine Demokratie
und die USA genügend rechtsstaatlichen
Grundsätzen auch wenn natürlich auch
dort die geheimdienstbehör die
nachrichtendienst-agenturen umfassende
ausspiele Befugnisse auch gegenüber den
Bürgern haben aber in China ist die
Situation eben gänzlich anders es gibt
keine unabhängige Datenschutz auf sich
im es gibt auch keinen Datenschutz
Grundrecht also Datenschutz als
verfassungsrechtliche Tradition sage ich
mal wie wir das in der Europäischen
Union oder eben auch in Deutschland
kennen und das chinesische
Datenschutzgesetz was sogar neuer ist
als die datenschutzgrundverordnung
enthält umfassende Regelungen wo eben
auch drin steht das für Zwecke
staatlicher Sicherheit nationaler
Sicherheit worunter natürlich auch
Geheimdienst Interessen zu fassen sein
können ähm Daten erhoben werden können
die dann eben nicht unter das
Datenschutzrecht fallen das ist eben
auch der gewaltige Unterschied weswegen
seitens der Vereinigten Staaten auch
diese Anschuldigungen zurzeit gemacht
werden zumindest im Hinblick auf den
Datenschutz
genau in dieser Debatte sprechen wir mal
ganz viel über Anschuldigungen wir
sprechen viel im Konjunktiv also könnte
das sind alles es ist alles im Bereich
des Möglichen und hier fragt auch jemand
aus der Community dazu können
IT-Experten die Daten nicht einfach
auslesen und dekodieren ob oder was
tatsächlich übermittelt wird
also so einfach ist das tatsächlich
nicht möglich weil wir sprechen ja hier
darüber was dann bei beiden Dance
tatsächlich passiert natürlich kann man
bestimmte Daten auslesen man kann
Metadaten auslesen aber daraus haben wir
natürlich kein Eindruck darüber was
beide letzten Endes als Anbieter dieser
App mit den Daten macht und die Gefahren
oder auch die Risiken die ja eben
geäußert werden sind eben dass die
chinesische Staat darauf Zugriff nimmt
das heißt das ist eben eine Dimension
die sich einem einfachen auslesen welche
Datenflüsse jetzt in einer App
stattfinden entzieht und das ist auch
das Problem warum wir natürlich im
Konjunktiv an dieser Stelle sprechen
aber nichtsdestotrotz
besteht eine Bedrohungslage für den
Datenschutz das ist definitiv der Fall
und es geht ja eben auch nicht nur um
den einzelnen tiktok Nutzer sondern
speziell auch darum dass diese Geräte ja
auch auf regierungs-handys genutzt
werden auf Dienst Telefonen genutzt
werden und da natürlich dann auch sehr
sehr viele sensible personenbezogene
Daten erhoben werden können und letzten
Endes komplette Persönlichkeit sprofile
gebildet werden können und das macht
tiktok definitiv das machen auch andere
Social Media Apps aber hier ist es eben
so dass nicht ausgeschlossen werden kann
dass diese Daten in technischer Hinsicht
und natürlich auch ein rechtlicher
hinsichtlich gerade dargelegt habe eben
unbefugten die im Ausland sitzen
zugänglich gemacht werden
ja wir sind ja in der EU schon mal so
weit dass Mitarbeitende der
EU-Kommission tiktok von ihren
Diensthandys löschen müssen das ist auch
in den USA und Kanada so können sie uns
noch mal erklären was ist der
Unterschied ist ob ich die tiktok App
auf meinem privaten Handy benutze vs ich
benutze diese App auf meinem Diensthandy
ja also es ist natürlich so dass bei
Diensthandys und wir sprechen hier auch
in erster Linie von regierungs-handys
oder Handys der Europäischen Kommission
darum dreht sich das Verbot ganz viele
Daten erhoben werden die eben mit den
personellen Besonderheiten mit dem
personellen Gegebenheiten von
Mitarbeitern von Regierungen von
Behörden der Europäischen Kommission
zusammenhängen und man kann natürlich
aus diesen Daten darauf schließen wo
sich bestimmte regierungsmittel
Mitarbeiter aufgehalten haben wo sich
vielleicht auch bestimmte Politiker
aufgehalten haben was Politiker
herausgehobene Menschen des öffentlichen
Lebens vielleicht auch für persönliche
Interessen haben das heißt wo sie länger
drauf verweilen was die scrollen was sie
sich vielleicht ansehen was sie liken
und das natürlich kombiniert mit den
ganzen persönlichkeitsstaaten den
Wetterdaten und natürlich auch noch den
geolokationsinformationen die tik tok
ebenfalls erhebt und zusätzlich auch die
umfassenden technischen
zugriffsbefugnisse auch weitere
technische also Eigenschaften des
Smartphones da sind natürlich ganz
erhebliche
Risiken das umfassende
Persönlichkeitsprofil gebildet werden es
ist natürlich so dass der Begriff
Spionage App etwas irreführend ist also
der chinesische Staat wird eben
natürlich nicht eine globale
Unterhaltungs- oder tanz-app die
natürlich in erster Linie für
Minderjährige für Jugendliche ist
ausrollen um gezielt jetzt westliche
Politiker auszuspielen das ist
fernliegend unter dem Gesichtspunkt und
da gibt es auch weitaus effektivere
Mittel um eben diese Leute unmittelbar
zu kompromittieren aber man sorgt sich
eben an dieser Stelle um den um den
Beifang der durch entstehen kann also so
gesehen besteht erstmal kein großartiger
Unterschied zu Privatpersonen es ist
natürlich so dass Privatpersonen unter
diesem Datenschutz Gesichtspunkt für den
chinesischen Staat wenn wir von
Geheimdienst Aktivitäten
Nachrichtendienst Aktivitäten sprechen
erst einmal weniger interessant ist und
darum dreht sich jetzt der Vorwurf erst
dann auch weniger sondern da geht es in
erster Linie darum dass eben durch das
Informationskampagnen durch Algorithmen
gesteuerte Ausspielung von bestimmten
Bilder n oder Anzeigen große Teile der
Bevölkerung eben auch in die Irre
geführt werden können oder manipuliert
werden können was aber ja auch kein
neues Thema ist und das hat man z.B auch
im Hinblick auf Facebook und den
trunction
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf und
entsprechende russische Manipulation vor
einigen Jahren gesehen dass der
Zweifelsfall mittlerweile auch
nachgewiesen werden konnte
lassen Sie uns jetzt noch mal zum
Schluss so ein bisschen den Blick weiten
tiktok ist ja nicht das einzige
chinesische Unternehmen mit dem die Welt
zusammenarbeitet mit dem wir hier in
West im Westen konfrontiert sind und
arbeiten und umgehen was gibt es denn
noch für chinesische Unternehmen bei
denen man gerade auch ganz gut erkennt
welche Strategien der Zusammenarbeit
sich da so erkennen lassen
also das ist sehr gute Frage weil wir
müssen das ganzheitliche Bild sehen man
hat das heute glaube ich ganz gut an der
kongressanhörung auch gesehen dass die
Würfel eben gefallen sind dass man sich
als US-Kongress dazu entschieden hat
jetzt Maßnahmen gegen tiktok zu
ergreifen und das ist ja sogar die Rede
gewesen von kommunistischen Gefahren die
sich dann jetzt irgendwie in den USA
abspielen könnten und das ist auch das
was wir zurzeit in in der Europäischen
Union in Deutschland erleben nämlich mit
dem Konzern Huawei also Huawei war ja
vor 10 bis 15 Jahren hierzuland ein
völlig unbekanntes Unternehmen man ist
dann mit Smartphones aus dem
Niedrigpreissegment erstmals auf den
Markt gegangen hat dann eben auch große
Teile der Bevölkerung mittlerweile für
chinesisches Smartphones gewinnen können
ist auch Preissegment aufgestiegen und
mittlerweile ist es tatsächlich auch so
das ganz erhebliche Teile des deutschen
Mobilfunknetzes also das ist 5g Netzes
eben im technischen Komponenten von
Huawei enthalten und da besteht zurzeit
auch die die Debatte und die Sorge dass
eben Sicherheitslücken vorhanden sein
könnten das ist zu Abhörmaßnahmen kommen
könnte oder weil ja auch das
Mobilfunknetz eine kritische
Infrastruktur ist das ist so eine Art
Killswitch geben könnte womit man eben
in der Lage ist von einem Tag auf den
anderen das Mobilfunknetz abzuschalten
deswegen wurden entsprechende
Komponenten auch von vom BSI also von
der deutschen cybersicherheitsbehörde
untersucht in technischer Hinsicht
konnte man jetzt erst einmal nichts
feststellen aber deswegen sind diese
verdachtsgrade also wir sprechen ja von
Möglichkeiten hier nicht ausgeräumt das
heißt tiktok ist letzten Endes nur ein
politisches Exempel muss man wirklich so
sehen was man hier auch statuieren will
zusammen auch mit Huawei und diese
Debatte ist auch in den USA dieulent um
zu sagen es bestehen Risiken wir können
China eben als Staat nicht trauen und
der sich zu spitzen in China Taiwan
Konflikt der ja auch in den nächsten
Jahren sich vermutlich erst einmal nicht
weiter abschwächen wird zeigt eben auch
die Gefahren an der Stelle und man
möchte eben nicht da stehen wie es mit
dem Russland Ukraine Krieg der Wahl
gewesen ist und mit den Abhängigkeiten
von Rohstoffen dass man auf einmal im
Falle eines China Taiwan Konfliktes
ebenfalls von chinesischen
technologieexporten und
technologieimport natürlich dann von
unserer Seite aus abhängig ist das heißt
man muss hier wenn man diesen tik tok
dieses tiktok Verbot auch betrachtet das
ganzheitliche sehen was eben diesen
geopolitisch strategischen Konflikt
zwischen Westen und China sehr sehr
deutlich auch nahegelegt
ja danke zum Schluss noch mal für diesen
Blick auf das größere Bild danke dass
Sie meine Fragen und die Fragen der
Community beantwortet haben
ich gucke zum Schluss noch mal was ihr
so zu dem Thema denkt und hier sind
immer noch viele Menschen die sich für
ein Verbot aussprechen so sagt Christian
korbock auf Youtube sollte gemacht
werden aber auch auf insta oder Romy rum
schaut auf Facebook sehr gut hoffentlich
wird wenigstens dort tiktok verboten die
chinesische Gefahr wird hier in
Deutschland einfach nicht erkannt und
hier schreibt Benny the best of Youtube
für mich ist tik Tokio überflüssig ja es
gibt auch kreativen Content aber in
meinen Augen überwiegt er Unsinn und es
ist ein massiver Zeitfresser ein Verbot
ist jetzt auch übertrieben ja für alle
die finden
gerne einfach mal öfter ZDF heute live
gucken ich freue mich wenn ihr wieder
einschaltet und bis zum nächsten Mal